good evening ladies and gentlemen I'm
Newton middle of siddeley in Austin I'm
a member of the Chicago committee of the
council about my wife Jo is a member of
the board and it's our honor and
pleasure tonight to welcome our friend
Bob rice to Chicago I'd like to remind
those of you see span is here tonight
you're on television so please be on
your best behavior and second if you've
got a cell phone or a pager please turn
it off Barbra schwee all know is an
exceptionally distinguished political
economist he served under three national
administrations and we all know this
Services Secretary of Labor in the first
Clinton administration he's currently a
professor at Brandeis and he has really
one of the most extraordinary careers of
any buddy in public life Bob's a
graduate of Dartmouth he got his
master's at Oxford where he studied
there with Bill Clinton and then he
joined Bill and Hillary Clinton at the
Yale Law School where he graduated in
nineteen seventy three he's also worked
at very high responsibilities in the
Department of Justice and in the Federal
Trade Commission we met Bob when he was
a professor at the Kennedy School
Government at Harvard our daughter
Martha was his colleague and a longtime
friend and I was his student because I
was a visiting fellow at Harvard and I
took his class in 1986 and I can testify
that he is not only brilliant but an
exceptionally effective teacher he's
written as we all have read important
pieces in The New Yorker the Atlantic
Monthly New York Times
l street journal and he's written eight
books tonight he's going to tell us
about his latest book the future of
success published by alfred nom bobs on
a book tour and i have to tell him a
story something happened to me when I
was on a book tour some years ago I
wrote a book and I was interviewed on
The Today Show in New York when I got
out I was walking up Fifth Avenue cast
that marvelous book store that's no
longer there that Scribner he had on
Fifth Avenue and I saw my book in the
window so I stopped to admire it in the
the salesperson recognize me because my
picture was in the book and she beckoned
me to come in I came in and she said Oh
mr. Minto would you mind autographing
copy of your book for me and I said I'm
deeply honored she said all mr. middle I
just wish my publisher had sent me 25
copies of your book to sell I was very
touched I said how many copies did my
publisher send you she said 500
I
there will be ample time to ask Bob
questions will be available to sign
books will have a reception later for
those of you who watch Ted Koppel's
Nightline and PBS Frontline in the last
week or so you've seen Bob asked about
what he thought about the Clinton
administration the legacy of the clinton
ministration he said on monday wednesday
and friday i think the clinton
administration did many good and
marvelous things on Tuesday Thursday and
Saturday I think what a waste of a
talent because of personal flaws on
Sunday he said I don't think about it
well i would say about bob rice on
monday wednesday and friday we think of
him as a great scholar and public
servant on Tuesday Thursday and Saturday
we think of him as an exceptionally
effective scholar and public servant and
on Sunday we think how lucky our
daughter Martha is to have him as a
friend Barbara
well Newt what a wonderful introduction
thank you for that I first came across
Nino and his thinking at work in 1961
when he coined the term referring to
television as that vast wasteland I was
only two years old at the time but it
remained with me Newton I wish I could
say the television is no longer a vast
wasteland and you are also in fact
particularly a great public servant and
I want to thank you for everything you
have done as you can see or maybe you
can't see years in Washington have worn
me down
politics that's that's really the issue
politics politics comes from the greek
root poly meaning many and ticks small
blood sucking insects
no i don't i don't mean that at all I
really no I don't mean that I I enjoyed
in fact I love my my tenure in the
Department of Labor and my opportunities
to serve the public before that and
indeed when it came time to leave the
Labor Department it didn't really come
time I discovered one evening and it was
a kind of a discovery that some of you
probably have had as well I had not been
home in about five nights i was working
18-hour days I hadn't seen anything of
my two kids who were at that time in
1996 they were 11 and 15 we had come to
Washington in 1992 they were obviously
younger I saw my wife episodic way and I
called home one night I promise to be
home and the President had called a
meeting at the White House I couldn't
get home and I called and my younger son
and son answered the phone and he said
dad you're going to get home and I said
Sam lie I'm terribly sorry I I just
can't make it home but i'll see you
tomorrow morning it's a school day i'll
see you tomorrow morning and he said at
that please wake me up when you come
home and I said said that's ridiculous I
you know i'll see you tomorrow morning i
don't want to interrupt your sleep and
he said please wake me up and i asked
him why it was so important and he said
because i just want to know you are here
with us and I can't tell you precisely
what happened at that moment but I felt
it like a dagger in my heart and it
sounds a little hokey but in fact I knew
at that moment that I had to leave that
job because even though it was the best
job I ever had the best job I'm sure I
ever will have I knew that I was
neglecting a more important job and that
was the job of being a dad
and so I told the president and i left
the administration and i came home and i
said to the kids and i said to my wife
i'm home and they said that's great we
have other things that we're doing
and I said to the boys well I'm
available at lay said that's great dad
will let you know when we have time you
know I don't know anything about
bringing up teenage girls I've never had
a teenage girl at home but I know a lot
about teenage boys and teenage boys are
like clam shells they're shut very tight
a lot of the time and occasionally they
open and when they opened you can see
that that soft and vulnerable and
beautiful interior for just a moment and
then they clam shuts again and if you
are not around when that clam shell
opens and you can't tell when it's going
to happen but if you're not around then
you might as well be on another planet
and so the Wonder and the beauty and the
delight of the last three and a half
four years for me has been that I've
been around for those moments and I have
seen those boys grow into young men and
one is off at college the other one is
almost off and I would not have given up
these years for anything but here's the
point when I did announce that I was
leaving I got a lot of letters and phone
calls and emails from a lot of people
not nearly all favorable in fact a lot
of them were quite upset with me some of
them said look you are lucky you have
the luxury you have the flexibility you
can get another job that pays almost as
well as your job as Secretary of Labor
and gives you enough time for your
family but I don't have that luxury I
have to work all hours because I have to
make ends meet if I didn't work all
hours I wouldn't have enough money to
support my family and what are you doing
you Secretary of Labor former Secretary
of Labor you are sending a signal that
is completely inappropriate to my life
means nothing suggests something that is
impossible
and then I got some letters and phone
calls and emails from women who said to
me what kind of a signal are you sending
former Secretary of Labor we we I have
spent my adult life trying to prove to
myself and to people around me that it
is possible to be on the fast track and
also to be a parent and a good parent
and what are you doing what are you
sending what signal are you sending a
very different one just the opposite you
are in effect saying that in order to be
an effective parent you've got to get
off the fast track and that is a signal
that not only do I not want to hear but
it's a signal that counters everything
that I stand for and everything that I
have tried to seek as a woman in this
new workplace and I got some letters
from people saying don't feel so proud
of yourself you gave up an important job
you should have stayed well I told
people in response that I didn't attempt
to send a signal I didn't try to send a
signal i just had to do what i thought
was right for me the problem that i had
got into my self into was that I wasn't
even aware up until that wake-up call
for my son I wasn't even aware what I
was doing I love the job so much that I
was not even aware that I was making a
choice and the only lesson that I made
or had that had any relevance to anybody
else's life was the lesson that you
ought to be at least aware of the
priorities that you are in effect
setting and the biggest danger
particularly if you love your job the
biggest danger is you may not be fully
aware of the choice you are implicitly
making but I didn't attempt to tell
other people what to do and yet that
experience both the transition from
being in the cabinet to being a father
and a husband and a normal person by the
way I should tell you parenthetically
you know you are no longer in the
president's cabinet when you get in the
backseat of your car and there's nobody
in the front seats
but I was impressed by the response and
troubled by a lot of the response and
also struck by how many people who wrote
me were struggling more they said than
they had struggled in the past and I put
that together with what i have learned
during the years I was Secretary of
Labor I conducted a kind of
free-floating focus group around the
country talking to people about their
lives and their work and I put that
together with what I knew as a a
professor a scholar who is researching
and had research for many years the
evolution of the American economy and it
turned out that despite the
extraordinary success of the economy
during the 1990s a very successful
economy and amazingly successful economy
the longest expansion on record it may
still be going on we don't know exactly
the economy is slowing clearly but it
was an extraordinary economy despite
that extraordinary economy American
families middle class families
middle-class couples turned out to be
working at the end of the 1990s a total
of seven weeks more per year if you
total all of the hours that they put in
a total of seven weeks more per year
than they were working at the start of
the 1990s and that trend transcended the
business cycle it was a trend that was
starting actually in the late 1970s
increasing in the 1980s Americans
working more and more and more hours
even though the economy was growing and
technology that was supposed to give us
all of this efficiency and more leisure
more time actually was doing just the
opposite somehow technology was
intruding even more and I don't mean
only getting us to work harder in
certain ways that I will explain but all
so it rooting on those times that we
thought were private emails and
voicemails and mobile phones and cell
phones and beepers to the point where we
almost in the back of our brains head of
the century that was on 24 hours waiting
for the next intrusion on our time and
that additional seven weeks extra
doesn't even include the longer commutes
it doesn't even include all of the
travel that many people now are doing on
work more than ever before what is going
on why are we not only working harder
but also why is there so much more
stress at work and again I investigated
polls samples my own free-floating focus
group interviews and everywhere I looked
regardless of socioeconomic place
regardless of where they were in the
latter people were saying to me the same
thing more work now more stress more
hours in fact ironically the more
education you have it seemed the more
people were working my own students a
few years into their work lives most of
them professionals were putting in not
40 not 45 but 50 55 60 75 hours per week
in their 20s in their 30s something was
happening something is happening and I
set out to figure out what was going on
and how structural changes in the
economy might explain at least some of
this because you see we all tell
ourselves and are involved in several
conversations at once they are private
conversations there is a kind of
national
private conversation going on about work
about the economy you hear it from your
friends and your relations you hear it
at work people say in their off moments
they say in fact there are three
conversations and one conversation is
about the wonders of this new economy
the Internet's computers new gadgets did
you hear about the gadget I just got the
Palm Pilot that whatever it is you know
what I can do it's extraordinary this is
a wondrous conversation it's a
conversation about new efficiencies and
gadgets and broadband and it's it's a
conversation really about the amazing
positive achievements technologically
and otherwise of this new economy it's
true it is true but then there is a
second conversation and I bet most of
you have been involved in the second
conversation and that is a very
different conversation it's one in which
we say to our very closest friends you
know I'm concerned that I may just be an
inadequate parents or if I have elder
parents I may it be an inadequate child
I can't attend to them to the extent
that i believe i should or i may be an
inadequate spouse or partner i just i'm
not connecting as i think i should or my
friendships my friendships are just not
what they should be on not seeing my
close friends or i'm an inadequate
member of my community i would like to
think that i would participate more but
i am just not participating as much as I
would like to that sense of personal
inadequacy or maybe I'm inadequate with
regard to my job that sense of personal
inadequacy I'm just not living up to my
ideal in one or more of these domains
it's a it's a conversation not about the
economy not about what is happening to
the world or the society it's a very
personal conversation and it's a very
private conversation and people think of
themselves personally as not quite doing
what they ought to be doing some how
and that there is a third and final
conversation that we have together some
of us not all of us but you tend to pick
up this third and final conversation on
the extreme left or the extreme right of
the political spectrum maybe not so
extreme it's a conversation about loss
of power and security to global
institutions to global capitalism to
immigrants to international trade two
forces that seemed somehow to have
undermined our Economic Security or
ability to predict and have sovereignty
over what we used to be able to control
and this is sometimes a very angry
conversation it is an angry conversation
again directed apps and blaming global
companies and capital and immigrants and
it makes a blaming conversation but I
want to suggest to you tonight is that
these three conversations the wondrous
new economy the personal inadequacy the
blame with regard to things getting out
of a control globalization these three
conversations are very very closely
related and they all miss in some sense
the essence of what is actually
happening they focus on symptoms they
don't focus on causes and so what I set
out to do in my book and what I will
give you a sampling of tonight but not
so much of a sampling that you don't
feel enormous incentive to go out and
buy
what I will try to do is give you a
sketch of what I think has been
happening and that really is at the core
the essence of the new economy and by
the way I believe that there is a new
economy yes it is slowing down yes there
is still a lot of basic industry there's
an electricity and energy crisis in
California there are all prices we can't
completely turn our backs on the old
economy but there is undoubtedly a new
economy that is changing a lot of what
we live in that new economy the essence
of it is this technology information
technology communication technologies
these technologies are allowing us as
consumers and investors to have far
greater choices of where to put our
money than ever before and not only
choices but making it far easier for us
to find a better deal and to switch to a
better deal and that better deal may be
anywhere around the world some of it may
be at the click of a mouse on the
internet some of it may be on a
telephone some of it may be anywhere it
may be that we are a business customer
it may be there were an individual
consumer but the heart of the matter is
that as consumers and customers we now
can more easily than ever before get a
better deal a product or a service or a
components that is cheaper that is
faster that is better
and that ability and by the way it also
applies to investors investors and
consumers investors can go anywhere can
also get a better deal investors and
consumers but consumers leading the way
because investors are simply trying to
see where there is likely to be a
prophet where the stocks where the
instruments financial instruments are
likely to go and how they are likely to
rise or fall but consumers are leading
the way and consumers ability to choose
and switch so easily is great for
consumers that's wonderful for consumers
it makes the entire economy more
efficient it makes the economy a kind of
textbook efficient economy it also
generates enormous innovation because it
means that every producer is locked in
much tighter competition with every
other producer and has to innovate has
to produce better and cheaper and faster
if it is going to survive and that's
great for us as consumers as well we
love innovation we should love
innovation it keeps the economy growing
very fast it generates higher
productivity it is in fact behind and it
is the secret I think no longer secret i
have now exposed it behind a lot of the
growth of the last not just the last 10
years but the last 20 years increasingly
but we are not just consumers and
investors
we are also people who work for a living
most of us we're also people who have
families who have friendships who exist
in webs of relationships and the story
with regard to the new economy for all
of those relationships is a very
different kind of story because follow
the logic follow the logic the easier it
is for consumers and investors to switch
the more that we as producers and
workers have to hustle in order to keep
or attract every customer in order to
maintain every client in order to grab
every consumer they are the two sides of
the same coin because the longer and
also the more intensively we've gotta
hustle the more we have to work the
greater the stresses the greater the
strains it used to be 20 or 30 years ago
most people had what we called steady
jobs and by steady jobs I don't mean
only that they had a job that was a
permanent or semi-permanent job I mean
that they could rely on their income
stream they knew approximately one year
to the next what they would be earning
and so they could enter into mortgages
and they could have debts they could
have car payments and they could pay
their utility bills because they knew
with some reasonable degree of certainty
what that income flow what that cash
flow is going to be but now fast forward
into the new economy and remember
consumers and investors are switching
fast and that means that we as producers
as employees increasingly are being paid
according to the demand for our services
somebody was talking to me yesterday
about his bill ability I said excuse me
what did you say
he said I'm talking about my bill
ability is going up I don't know what
you mean bill ability bill ability bill
ability a professional who is billing
his or her hours bill ability is
directly related to one's income and
cash flow commissions more people are
being paid by commissions these days
more people our franchisees more people
are contractors independent contractors
more people are freelancers or eel
answers or they are otherwise free
agents in this new economy even if they
have a so-called steady job they are
paid for their performance more and more
it's in the university to my university
other universities how many tenured
slots are there as a proportion of total
faculty slots the tenured professor yeps
continues to decline in America I have
tenure I am a vanishing species more and
more of the teaching in a typical
university is done by part-timers by
academic nomads by post graduates who
are paid or underpaid or over works they
are in a microcosm exactly like all the
rest of the young contract workers of
America some of them doing very well by
the way contract workers but not all the
point is you're getting paid more and
more according to your marketability the
demand for your services and that means
by the way that means that you've got to
make hay while the Sun shines if you've
got a lot of demand for your services
today you're going to take that demand
now you're going to work now 1214 hours
you're not going to wait till maybe
there's not a demand for your services
last week I was talking to a freelancer
working at a local radio station I asked
her how many hours she was putting in
she said well I'm putting in about nine
hours a day I said well that's that's
pretty good she said at this job
she has two jobs sometimes three jobs
and she is putting in extraordinary
hours she has she's a single parent she
has a child I said well why are you
doing this she said well as long as
there's demand for my services as long
as they want me I better do it I better
do it this point was driven home to me
when I came home from working in
Washington I thought that I was free of
all of these pressures my elder son was
running a cross-country race the weekend
coming up and I was going to be able to
be there and I felt great and he felt
great and I was going to be able to see
him to France like a gazelle across the
meadows of Massachusetts and the race
was coming up in two days before the
race I got a telephone call from
somebody who said we have a great
project we would like you to get
involved in it starts in a couple of
days and by the way it's going to pay
you a lot of money I asked how much and
my pupils dilated
and then I hung up the phone and
realized oh no wait a minute this
project is going to happen at the same
time as my son's cross-country race I
can't possibly do both of them and I was
in a dilemma I had to make a choice it
was another choice I had assumed that by
leaving Washington I was over those
kinds of dilemmas and choices but here
it was smack down in front of me again
and I am well somewhat proud I suppose
you could say although pride is not the
right word to tell you that I turned
down that offer and I saw the race but I
wish that I could tell you that I did
not have any regrets because now that I
had had that offer and I turned it down
as I saw my son prance across the
meadows of Massachusetts I could not
help at least once or twice or four
times during that afternoon
tell myself how much this experience was
costing me
you see before the telephone call it was
free making hay while the Sun shines it
is a very profound part of the new
economy and it is closely related to
another phenomenon which is fast track
versus slow track and company after
company and job after job profession
after profession there are only two
tracks there is the fast track the track
on which you are keeping up with clients
keeping up with customers keeping up
with new technologies you are in the
inside loop and then there is the slow
track if you get off the fast track
there are not tracks in between you want
to take advantage of family-friendly
policies go ahead go ahead yes a lot of
firms they proudly say we are family
friendly we have all sorts of
opportunities for flex time and flex
place and we have opportunities for you
to go home and you can have a child and
you can be a parents and then you can
come back you can do all sorts of things
yes yes we have those policies but then
they say such a voce but we expect a
hundred fifty percent commitment if
you're going to be on the fast track to
higher levels of responsibility and
promotion and partnership or whatever
else inducement is there you can take
advantage of all of these other
family-friendly policies but you better
know that is going to put you on the
slow track and you can forget about all
of these wonderful promotions and
inducements and maybe you can forget
about even being here for a long time
fast track and slow track it is not
because anybody is acting maliciously
it's not because companies are our or
partnerships or service companies are
being bad to employees it's because the
competitive pressures are so intense
that you are either on the fast track
and you are meeting those competitive
pressures or you are on this sludge
reckon you are marginalized
and so many young people not only women
but also young men have to make that
painful decision which would not be
nearly as painful if there were a lot of
gradations of track between fast and
slow track they've got to decide between
in the new economy fast track or slow
track and finally widening inequality
widening inequality is also both a
function and also a source of the
dilemmas we face it is in a sense and
consequence a consequence of the new
economy because the people who are
well-educated who are innovative who are
creative who can come up with ways of
creating faster and cheaper and better
products they are in great demand in
greater demand than ever before
companies want them consumers want them
investors want them their compensation
is going up but if you are a routine
worker if you are simply doing the same
thing over and over again blue collar or
pink color or whatever color you want to
describe if you are simply doing routine
work and you can so easily be replaced
in the new economy by software or
hardware or by somebody in another
nation doing it more cheaply than you
supply and demand is working in exactly
the opposite direction and the
competitive pressure is on businesses
are pushing your wages and compensation
downward and what is the consequence of
that widening inequality the elongation
of the job ladder it means that the
people who are in the bottom third have
to work harder merely to maintain their
standard of living and the people in the
top third are working harder because the
opportunity costs to them of not working
hard
getting off the fast track of taking a
break of not becoming a partner of not
working all those hours the opportunity
cost is larger than it ever was before I
was talking not long ago to one of my
former students a very very bright
bright woman she had all kinds of
opportunities she decided to go into
Investment Banking some of you may be
investment bankers it is a noble
profession I don't know why you do it
but it is a noble profession no I'm
being specific an important profession
it is you are in fact the air traffic
controllers of modern capitalism she
went into that doesn't quite work does
it she went into Investment Banking and
she likes her job and I talked to her
recently and I asked her how she's doing
she said fine and I asked her well how
are you really doing there was something
in her voice that didn't sound exactly
right and she said well to tell you the
truth I am working I'm working 16 17
hours a day I don't I don't have a life
I I'm beginning to think that maybe
maybe I'm not going to have a family or
I'm confused I don't know what I'm doing
I and she is facing that same dilemma
the opportunity cost for her the
opportunity cost of not working those
hours is very large she is earning 120
130 hundred forty thousand dollars a
year she is only 26 years old think of
those inducements
there are some people who look at what
has happened to the modern family look
at the fact that people are waiting many
many more years before getting married
in fact the rate of barrage in this
country is at an all-time low look at
the fact that families are shrinking
family sizes is getting smaller people
are having fewer children look at the
fact that in fact there are more single
people than ever before in household
formations and they say to themselves
there is something morally wrong there
is a moral breakdown of some sort and
they look at the fact that we are not
nearly as involved in our communities as
we used to be that our own personal
integrity is sometimes more compromised
with regard to our friendships and they
say to themselves there is a moral
problem here there's a cultural decline
some people in Washington now hold this
view the moral conservatives the social
conservatives they hold that there has
been a fundamental moral decline in
America well maybe there has been but
they are not looking at the 3,000 pound
gorilla in the center of the room and
that gorilla is the changing nature of
work and the economy and what that has
meant the strange that that has put on
families and on communities there are
things that we can do by the way I am
very very hopeful as I have gone on with
this lecture and looked out it your
faces and seen you get glum ER and
sadder and more morose I realized that I
have not shared with you my upbeat
attitude and my
my very optimistic sense that we are not
simply victims and passive recipients of
this new economy I am NOT an economic
determinists or a technological
determinist at heart I really do believe
that we can make changes I mean after
all a hundred years ago at the dawn of
the mass production era this country had
a similar set of choices we looked upon
the wonders of mass production and all
of the new factory jobs and the middle
class that was being created and all of
these new goods and services and washing
machines and refrigerators and all kinds
of things that were available to us and
we said that's wonderful but we also saw
that there were excesses child labor 60
or 70 hour work weeks for laboring men
and women sweatshops unsafe working
conditions a lack of social security
antitrust laws were not there at least
until eighteen ninety industry was a
glum rating and prices were not
necessarily going down we looked at all
of this and we said let's not throw the
baby out with the bathwater let's not
reject industrialization let's try to
come up with ways of keeping the best
aspects of mass production but removing
the excesses the in justices and we did
it it was a struggle but we did it in
the first decades of the 20th century it
was a transition we all had to make into
what was then considered to be the new
economy
well I want to suggest to you that we
are now in another transitional period
into the new economy that is a truly
post mass production economy an economy
that is very differently organized a
technological digital economy from which
we can get great benefits and that holds
all sorts of promise and opportunities
to us let's not throw it out let's not
put up trade barriers let's not try to
be neo-luddites and wreck the technology
let's not stop capital from flowing from
one place to another let's preserve what
is best about the dynamism of this new
economy but let's also at the same time
acknowledge recognize that there are
some negative aspects to this new
economy negative aspects with regard to
what we as individual people in our
families and communities and
relationships need and let us search for
ways to remove the excesses and the
injustice 'as so that the economy serves
us so the new economy works for us
rather than the other way around by the
way I think this set of issues this
debate this discussion will be the most
important and central debate and
discussion about domestic policy that we
have in this country in the coming years
if you ask me whether my book is going
to become the Bible of the new Bush
administration in Washington I must
confess some doubts
but on the other hand if they are
pragmatic and as compassionate as they
say they are I do hope they buy the book
and my telephone is open to them I'm
standing by ready to give advice but I
say quite seriously to you there are
things that we can do and if we have
time and if i had time tonight i could
go through many many many changes in
policy but it's not just policy it's not
just government it's also our own
personal attitudes our own
understandings of what the meaning of
success is and could be in our new age
understanding the trade-offs that we are
making not waiting for the wake-up call
that I waited for with regard to my
children and understanding the
responsibilities and opportunities that
employers have in this new economy as
well much to talk about I want to thank
you all for coming tonight and I will
entertain your questions about these
themes and any other themes you have but
we are all standing at the brink of a
very very different era and I have
absolute confidence and this is my final
uplifting note that in America of all
places in America when we understand the
nature of a problem we put ideology
aside we don't really worry about
whether we're Republicans or Democrats
liberals or conservatives we roll up our
sleeves we are pragmatic we do what we
need to do and we shall do so again
thank you
you can see why Bob's book has gotten
such marvelous reviews and we urge all
of you to read it and bob has about a
half hour for questions then we're going
to have a reception and if you would
please raise your hand and identify
yourself we'll take the first question
yes dan Heyman and that would like to
ask you your opinion about two books
that Bobo's in Paradise and Bowling
Alone other comments about what you can
talk about if you all hear the course
let me repeat the question then him and
asked me my opinion about two books
Bobo's in Paradise and Bowling Alone
well I haven't read the former the
latter is written by a colleague of mine
former colleague of mine Bob Putnam
about the decline of our civic life in
terms of the data that shows that
Americans are not nearly joining up and
participating as much as they did before
I think it's a wonderful book and the
data are very convincing I think my only
criticism is that I don't think he pays
enough attention to the issues that I
think are at the heart the economic
issues that are at the heart of the
matter yes you've mentioned the old new
economy at the turn of the century which
had excess esas in monopoly in labor
exploitation and so forth would your
outline which you see think are the
dimensions of the excesses today that
need to be addressed particular topic
areas the question is I talked about the
old economy and the progressive eras
response to what were then its excesses
or perceived too busy x-axis what would
be my list of the excesses of the new
economy well let me give you an example
for it in the old economy one of the
great threats one of the threats was
that the business cycle when it turned
downward would cause the economy to
contract and you to lose your job and
therefore unemployment insurance lasting
about 16 weeks for a full-time worker
came to be one of the methods of
insuring against the possibility that
you might not
have enough money to pay the bills and
then when the economy turned up again as
that business cycle tended to do after
about 16 weeks you would get your old
job back again you were laid off the
whole concept of being laid off implied
that you would be back on that same job
after the downturn in the new economy
that is not what is going on in the new
economy the chance that you if you lose
your job going to get your old one back
again is very very little it's not
because of dips in the business cycle
that most people are losing their jobs
and indeed one of the great threats that
people face is not so much the loss of
job as loss of income you may still keep
your job but you're paid in bill ability
and commissions your contract workers
you just may simply find that you're not
making it and what we need to think
about and I talked about this in the
book as just one of many examples
instead of unemployment insurance we
might want to think about earnings
insurance a way of for a certain amount
of time until you get the training you
need at least paying a certain
difference between what you were earning
a year ago and what you might be running
this year and we could talk about the
mechanics I don't think it's that
complicated or to take another example
along the same lines suppose you want to
be a part time worker unemployment
insurance doesn't help you if you lose
your job unemployment insurance comes
from a time when we were dealing with
full-time workers usually male
breadwinners in the family today a lot
of people would like to be part time
workers there's nothing for them no
earnings insurance if they lose their
part-time job that reflects
proportionately the kind of earnings
they had now we could talk about many
many other things and I don't want to I
don't want to take up your time with a
lot of policy wonk discussions okay I
will
no I won't but but but you see I don't
think we're talking necessarily about
big government about huge government
programs no we're talking about adapting
adapting our public policies adapting
our rules and norms to a new economy so
that we have some degree of social
tranquility and peace of mind so that we
have the economic dynamism but we
balance it appropriately with other
mechanisms that give us a chance to live
our lives more fully yes Jim Michaels
you'd mentioned about there's a fast
track and a slow trick how do we go
about getting a couple other tracks in
the middle there so there's maybe four
options of tracks because it sounds like
the rich will get richer the poor get
poorer there there's there's real
problems there's or is there a couple
things that we can do to get to gain a
couple more tracks the question is can
we gain a couple more tracks rather than
just fast track and slow track and by
the way fast track and slow track when I
use those metaphors I did not mean fast
track was for the rich and slow track
was for the poor we find in professional
occupations fast tracks and slow tracks
slow tracks paying pretty well but just
not leading anywhere being marginalized
there are many things that we can do and
by the way it's not all government by
any means a very good employer a very
good employer will not just think short
term that I've got to run everybody full
speed ahead in order to maintain those
contracts and those connections in those
clients a very good employer is going to
know that the only way to attract and
keep really good people and avoid the
enormous costs of turnover which are now
among the highest costs that many
employers face that employer is going to
know that he or she has got to treat
employees as whole people as whole
people as employees who have lives that
they must lead outside work that
employer is going to respect the fact
that for example we need some private
time where we can turn off the beepers
and the cell phones and the emails and
really have
to think and contemplate and be
ourselves and not get off the fast track
simply because we want to do that or
take care of a loved one so that
family-friendly policies are genuine
they are not just lip service but that
means that employers have to take a
long-term view yes over here yes Gerald
Leland a subject that just seems to pop
up all over the world and never gets to
be salvaged the subject of
hospitalization for the University for
four people everything has been tried we
have the the inherent problems of the
groups of people that are very unhealthy
that nobody seems to want and I was one
of your comments about hospitalization
has been tried different countries and
if you were in charge what would you do
the question is hospitalization and
health care I suppose you made more
generally how do we get the health care
to people who now don't have it and by
the way when i came to the clinton
ministration when wit began in 1992 1993
there were about thirty eight million
Americans who did not have health
insurance and now we're up to 45 million
Americans without health insurance it is
a big problem a growing problem and so
the second part of the question was well
what would I do if I were in charge
I would urge very strongly upon the
nation but it's called a single party
payer plan that is the essentially the
health care plan that most members of
Congress have that to me would be the
most efficient way of doing it and you
could keep your own doctor there's a lot
of a lot of flexibility in that kind of
plan but you see because we're all
together in the same plan it enables us
to get huge bargaining leverage with
regard to pharmaceuticals and hospitals
and everything else we need and it also
reduces the marketing and transaction
costs that now occupy and demand a
higher and higher percentage of
healthcare are we going to get a single
party payer plan anytime soon no short
of that what do I suggest well I think
their ways a beginning and I think that
the insuring of children which we just
began in the clinton ministration is
probably the first thing that we must
continue to do as the as the moderator
i'm allowed to ask a question they tell
me one of the things you did in the
government was the family leave law
which changed things would you tell us
exactly what you dreamed about when you
started it and how it's worked out well
the Family and Medical Leave Act was a
tremendous struggle it went on and I
don't think the clinton ministration and
certainly not i should take credit for
getting that done it was a struggle that
went on years 78 years people fought for
that and what we got at the end was
better than nothing it is 12 weeks of
unpaid leave if you have to go home for
a family emergency deal with your
children deal with a very sick parent
but not many Americans working Americans
have taken advantage of Family Medical
Leave when they have it's been a godsend
for them
i'm giving you the no spin version it's
so wonderful to be out of government for
years now I've been able to tell you
exactly an audience is exactly what I
thought without any consequence at all
of course I have no influence and no
megaphone but the downside the Family
Medical Leave Act the reason it's not
being taken advantage of very much is
that many people cannot afford to take
12 weeks of unpaid leave and we are the
only advanced nation we are the only
advanced nation that does not have paid
leave for family emergencies and here
again I think we just need to think more
creatively about what all of us needs
the business community in Washington the
Washington lobbies by the way let me
just say this very clearly the
Washington lobbies for the American
business community reflect very often
the lowest common denominator they don't
truly respond to what the advanced and
progressive elements in the business
community want to do or stand for they
simply fight and they fought the Family
and Medical Leave Act because they said
it would cost enormous enormous many
many billions of dollars to American
business obviously it is not but let me
just reassure you and in the context of
this discussion I think it should be
clear if we had paid leave and people
felt a little bit more confident that
they could go home and not reduce their
cash flow in the event an emergency that
might mean yes that business had to pay
a little bit more and those bills that
expense would be passed on to consumers
and consumers would have to pay a little
tiny bit more but that insurance would
go a long way to easing some of the
stresses some of the stresses that so
many American families now feel and it's
worth that little little tiny extra
expense in my view we will have to deal
with that one too why
yes Oh Bob what are we now in perhaps a
full generation of these steely-eyed
determined young men and women that went
through the the consulting and
investment banking phase then they
e-commerce themselves and dotcom
themselves and other all back a whole
generation that has been has played this
hard rough game and they don't they
don't have a lot of role models around
except maybe an occasional parent like
this 26 year old that you described does
this book or will a future book of yours
deal with the effect of this these very
well-trained very bright Americans who
are not typically involved in community
service or in family life in on the old
models what's the effect on America of
this our best and brightest being
different kinds of competitive animals
what what pushes what's the effect on
America of many very talented and young
people basically being chewed up by work
although let me stress to you a lot of
them love it they love the work in fact
that's the most insidious type of work
when you love it it's what happened to
me what's the effect well I do get into
it in my book
this is a hell of a book I'm an artist
and at each great advice sometimes I
think about my concerns about
industrialization and how texts the
environment and population growth and
that's all about consuming its
contributes to this this very exciting
consumer environment we've got going but
I'm often criticized as far as about
being concerned about those things how
my concerns may bring me down a road
make sure I repeat your question I sure
I understood it and kind of generalize
it to this discussion are you are you
asking a question about consumerism
generally and whether we are as a
society almost too consumed with
consumerism yes and how that is taxing
the environment but yet I have
economists and people who are investment
bankers who criticize me saying or you
can't think that way because it over let
me clarify something that causes a great
deal of unnecessary confusion when we
grow as an economy according to the
scale of gross national product or
become more productive that productivity
can be used for all sorts of purposes it
could be used to clean the environment
it can be used for public health it can
be used to improve the quality of life
in a variety of ways it doesn't
necessarily have to be used for more
gadgets more stuff in other words
consumerism or excessive consumerism if
that's the way you view it is not the
inevitable natural necessary byproduct
of economic growth economic growth can
be good in all kinds of dimensions for
all sorts of social purposes in my book
in terms of my own values I think that a
lot of us as middle and upper-middle and
wealthy people could slow down and
simplify our lives and I think we do
generate much too much stuff and we
pollute the air and we don't care
adequately about the consequences of our
consuming habits for the rest of our
world not even to mention the rest of
our society but that's my values that's
my values but again don't mix that up
with productivity and there are many
people who are in the bottom half who
are not able to consume as much as
perhaps they'd even need you have
another one in the back there
yeah any prize in the last century or
two there have been sources of social
criticism such as the jungle and cabot
that have driven social change and
economic change you think with the app
in the internet and new media that
commercial criticism will actually
continue to change how we think about
labor and the economy a question of will
the new media the internet and the new
media change the way we carry on if I
can paraphrase your question a public
discussion and public debate about some
of the issues that I've been talking
about tonight well I certainly hope so
my fear and I want to express that along
with my hope my fear is that the new
media including the internet tends to
narrow casts our debates within tiny
little communities of people who think
alike so we can more easily find people
who share our values and views and
become even more assured that we are
correct rather than expose ourselves to
a wider array of dissonance and
competing views the challenge our
fundamental assumptions and the public
square if that's the way and the
metaphor you want to use the public
square public debate free debate it
really is ideally a debate among people
who don't share the same assumptions but
or willing to be respectful and listen
to each other and modify their own
assumptions if they are persuaded and
that's what I fear we are losing in this
country I think we can take two more
let's take one right here thank you
as a very proud member of a labor union
what can labor unions do to increase
their membership and become a very
influential force in the new economy
question is what can labor unions do to
increase their numbers and their force
and become an even more influential
force in the new economy organized labor
has suffered in terms of numbers
membership and it is quite a dramatic
decline in the mid-1950s over a third of
all working Americans belong to a labor
union now if you look at the private
sector less than ten percent of private
sector workers are unionized now part of
that has to do with the fact that the
core of unionization in this country was
the manufacturing sector and there are
fewer and fewer manufacturing workers as
not only do we outsource around the
world but we put more robots and
numerically controlled machine tools and
more technology in factories there just
simply fewer of those jobs so the future
of labor unions are certainly one major
future for labor unions to me at least
is in the low income service sector in
health care in hospitals in hotels and
surface transportation and places that
are not necessarily competing
internationally but places where you
find concentrations of low-income
workers who really do need a voice
really do need some bargaining leverage
in our society this will be our last
question let's go over here to the
center right yes
Betty Jo oil would you do anything about
the minimum wage
Betty Doyle asks whether I would do
anything about the minimum wage I
planted Betty's question no I didn't
Betty we did as you remember several
years ago raised the minimum wage from
four dollars and twenty-five cents to 5
15 an hour it's still very low now
granted not all workers who are near the
minimum wage our family heads it is a
blunt instrument many people are at the
minimum wage are teenagers and others
but sixty percent of minimum-wage
workers have a substantial if not major
only role in supporting their families
and we do need to raise the minimum wage
now there was a huge fight in Washington
the last time we tried people told me
that it was hopeless this was old
democratic politics why go back to the
old minimum wage dick armey and I don't
want to be partisan in this room there
are Republicans here but I just want to
recount a little history dick armey the
majority leader of the Republicans at
the time said to me that he would resist
a minimum wage increase with every fiber
of his being now dick armies a big guy
he's got a lot of fibers in that being
I'm I'm pretty small i have very few
fibers but I said to him no I
I think we oughta ray and we fought we
really did have a really a battle royal
and it turned out that when Congress
learned that eighty-five percent of
Americans you know I'm not i hate polls
I hate opinion polls I hate governing
through opinion polls but this was one
instance where it paid off Dick Morris
by the way everything that is wrong that
has happened in America I blame on dick
Moore dick morris did a poll and when
and I suggested you do a poll and he
found out that eighty-five percent of
americans supported an increase in the
minimum wage eighty-five percent people
were amazed because there were only
about eight nine ten percent of workers
who would be affected even fewer than
that by an increase in the minimum wage
but eighty-five percent supported it why
why because it seemed the right and fair
thing to do and I think politicians
underestimate the extent to which
Americans will respond to a policy
initiative simply because it feels to be
and seems to be the fair and right thing
to do even if it doesn't benefit me and
we raised the min wage but it needs to
be raised again I think the Earned
Income Tax Credit now I every time I say
this eyes glaze over it is the worst
name you can possibly put on a piece of
legislation but the Earned Income Tax
Credit which is a wage subsidy is
probably more effective than the minimum
wage but you do both of them you raise
the minimum wage and expand the Earned
Income Tax Credit so that no working
person no working person should have his
or her family in poverty in the United
States a very simple principle
thank you all so much